at 6:30 a.m. nana guru banitsa fetches
the hot water like she does every
morning the cow's udder has to be
cleaned before milking a little later as
well as the family's breakfast she makes
cheese it requires a lot of patience she
can tell the cheese is ready when the
consistency is just right everything
here runs like clockwork with no time
for breaks I have a lot of work to do I
clean make the food milk the cows and
lots of other things there's always
something to do
nana guru banitsa is 60 and was a nurse
for 30 years she lives with her husband
son daughter-in-law and grandchildren
I always need hot water I'm glad we have
this system they received a
solar-powered water heater from a local
Energy Cooperative I saved up a bit of
money and sold a few things it was my
husband who really wanted this it's
quite expensive but it is manageable was
he trying to make her daily work easier
I think it was mainly about saving
electricity but I can't say for sure
when we had the wood stove he had to go
out collecting firewood and make sure we
had enough so maybe that had a lot to do
with it that I should forget the cheese
is ready not angora banitsa is going to
take it to the market
people here bring produce they grow or
make at home like vegetables fruit herbs
and cheese
mrs. Nana has barely unpacked before a
trader comes and buys the lot depending
on the type of cheese she pays between
one year of fifty and two euros fifty a
kilo but if you live frugally you get by
we try to get by on it
Lisa baklava is also in charge of the
housework in her home plus the farm and
the grandchildren she still heats water
the traditional way on a wood-burning
stove in the living room she needs a lot
of hot water and therefore a lot of wood
her annual wood supply costs between 200
and 240 euros in Georgia average income
is under three and a half thousand euros
a year we save money so we can afford
the wood but sadly there are a lot of
families who don't manage we're doing
better than some we can pay for firewood
the poor families can't
the men collect wood from high up in the
forests of the Caucasus Mountains
they're still allowed to fell trees here
go get a high flat say is 27 he comes
here regularly
[Music]
go Gaeta estimates that each and every
house in his area consumes about two to
three truckloads of wood every year if
we cut down trees anywhere else we could
cause rockslides which are dangerous for
the residents the forest might seem lush
but deforestation is rife across Georgia
the number of trees being cut has to be
limited to ensure long-term
sustainability currently over 12 times
that number is being felled the work of
these two mechanics is helping to solve
the problem
they're cutting solar panels the Machine
dates back to World War two but it still
works they're part of the energy
cooperative the systems they produce
here should help to reduce wood burning
and therefore carbon dioxide emissions
the co-operative has provided
solar-powered water heaters to more than
100 homes in the village mafia telethon
Yanni
is a 39 year old teacher and head of the
Energy Cooperative its name means turn
on the Sun the system is being installed
here today and they know that banks are
providing loans for them we don't have
to go from door to door people who are
interested come to us
Murrieta has been using the system
herself and she's impressed that's what
I made marks the goose I've had one at
home for three years already it's great
it saves money and makes the house work
easier Nana guru Bennett says back from
the markets and the grandchildren are
awake her son and daughter-in-law are at
work so she has to look after the
children no time for a break
it's horrible and 60 years old and I
think my life is almost over
I'd do anything to get my children and
grandchildren a better future I hope
they have a better life and hot water
straight from the tap is a good place to
start